so to go about wanting to manifest
material abundance in your life is
perhaps not the the right way to go
about it because you're concentrating on
the outermost layer of abundance and
even if you manage to manifest abundance
on the outer level it's not going to
make you happy it's not going to fulfill
you except for a few days the new
possession nice and shiny whatever it is
and there you look at it got it now it's
mine and after a few days it wears off
it's no longer that fulfilling to be
driving the Ferrari or whatever it is
there's nothing wrong with the Ferrari
but if you're looking to ferrariate for
happiness and fulfillment it's not going
to work for that long if you're just
driving it because you enjoy that
experience it's a different matter many
people who practice manifesting which of
course manifesting is a something that
you can and use and it works if it's
done rightly but the Dilemma or the
fallacy is the belief that whatever you
manifest is going to make you happy is
to seek the fullness of life through
what you manifest through things hey
seven Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I struggle
to stay afloat I quit I'm a business
partner and the thing that kept me
motivated kept me going was studying the
stories of famous successful
entrepreneurs and in their stories it
gave me the hope the drive the ambition
the thinking that maybe I can do it too
that extra bit of belief and I still
need their stories today and I'm honored
to share them with you here as well so
today let's learn how to make
manifesting part of your routine
enjoy
rule number two learn to get Beyond
yourself with Joe dispenza when you
begin to create from the field
instead of from matter the only way you
can do that is you have to learn how to
take all of your attention off your body
and become a nobody
take all of your attention off all the
people in your life that you give so
much of your attention and energy to
because you have an emotion associated
with them and get beyond all the people
in your life and go from someone to a no
one now if you've worked your whole life
being a someone or if you've been
working your whole life thinking that
you're your body you're gonna have to
work a little harder because that's your
identity that's what you're associated
with and it's a long time of
conditioning and if this was easy
everybody would be doing it so then you
have to go get beyond all the things in
your life your cell phone your computer
your car
and literally go from something to
nothing if I take all your attention off
the place you work the place you live
the place you need to be the place
you're sitting and go from somewhere to
nowhere
you got to stop thinking about the
predictable future in the familiar past
and go right into the present moment and
go from some time to no time and if you
do that properly
you become pure Consciousness and that's
how you enter the field now we've done
the research on this we call it getting
beyond the self now once you are pure
Consciousness you're taking all of your
attention off this three-dimensional
reality now where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
so if you've taken all of your attention
off of everything material there's only
one place you're going to wind up and
that is the in in material realm called
the quantum field an invisible field of
energy that unifies and connects
everything material
so now when you're creating from the
field and you combine a clear intention
with an elevated emotion and you're
connected and you feel connected
the suggestion of an alternative way to
create is that when there's a
vibrational match between your energy
and some future reality
you actually no longer have to go
anywhere to get it you're actually the
vortex and you will collapse space and
time and draw the experience to you now
that to me is a lot more fun because the
experience is the unknown you can't
predict when it's going to happen or how
it's going to happen because if you can
predict it it's known so then you have
to lay down the very thing
you use your whole life to get what you
want
for something greater to occur now that
goes against
Generations Untold of conditioning and a
lifetime of habituation believing that
we're we're trapped in this material
world and yet I can I can say to you
without a doubt
then once you understand that formula
and once you know how to create that
kind of brain and heart coherence the
side effect of that
is a change in biology
neurologically chemically hormonally
genetically we've measured it we've seen
Gene regulation changes in four days
more brain coherence more heart
coherence your brain's working better
your heart is you're trusting your heart
it's open there's different chemicals
that are released oxytocin suppresses
survival centers resets the Baseline of
a person's trauma or shock
your immune system goes up
you you lengthen your telomeres we've
measured that too so you're changing the
future of your body you're extending
your life
that's evidence right so we we have the
evidence to know that it could happen
because we've measured it but the real
evidence
is watching the testimonial of someone
who says I had stage four cancer I was
told as a 41 year old woman that I
wouldn't live for more than two months
and I have no evidence of cancer in my
body at all or someone that's a
physician who has Parkinson's disease
that's tried everything from the medical
route and has one transcendental moment
and their Tremors and their pain are
gone that now they're chewing food
they're swallowing they're blowing their
nose they're standing up on their own uh
that's energy affecting matter so we
have
hundreds and hundreds of testimonials of
people that not only heal their body but
created pretty profoundly magical things
in their life
so you have evidence in the scientific
world you have evidence in the Practical
world and evidence
is the loudest voice right now rule
number three practice proper manifesting
with Mel Robbins manifesting is
intentionally
training your brain and your nervous
system to believe in something that
hasn't happened yet
that's what manifesting is manifesting
is a power tool it's backed by
Neuroscience it is backed by years of
research and when used properly
it helps you achieve your goals because
it helps you prepare to do the work I
use
science-backed manifesting tools every
single day to shut down the negative
conversations in my life and to live a
big life and to take big risks and dude
Olympic athletes use manifesting and
we're going to get into how Olympic
athletes and the world's leading you
know Business Leaders and successful
people everywhere use it but I'm telling
you right now the way you shut down your
internal
conversation that is holding you back is
manifesting manifesting is one of the
first things you have to learn how to do
to get started on making this a reality
so what is manifesting manifesting is
mentally training
forgetting what you want that's all that
it is it is part of the toolkit that
successful people around the world use
let me tell you what manifesting is not
manifesting is not thinking thoughts and
then hoping they come through
that is what people do on their seventh
birthday and they blow out the candles
that is not what we are doing here
manifesting is based in neuroscience
it is a tool that you are going to use
precisely intentionally systematically
with purpose
because you use manifesting to re-wire
your mind and your body and your spirit
to help you do the work to achieve your
dreams
when you use manifesting properly
you are removing the mental obstacles of
self-doubt resistance fear perfectionism
feeling overwhelmed other people's
expectations all that stuff that is
holding you in place right now that
makes you spin in circles manifest and
clears that out and it programs
using science a completely different way
of thinking and feeling about the things
that you want to create in your life and
when you manifest properly it's almost
like the pregame training that you do
before the big game It prepares you to
take action it boosts your confidence it
gets you ready to do that thing also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four understand how
the brain works with Tara sworn Bieber
in the last 25 years or so we have had
much more sophisticated brain scanning
technology which shows how the brain
works prior to that we really understood
a lot of how the brain works from seeing
what happens when it goes wrong so if
somebody has a stroke or a brain tumor
or a brain injury once we could scan
healthy brains we started to learn a lot
more about this concept of
neuroplasticity which is that the brain
grows and changes throughout life
now you've got two little girls so you
will know that from zero to two they
went from being completely vulnerable
and helpless to walking talking being
able to control their bladder and bowels
and you know maybe even speaking several
languages and having an opinion so it's
a massive burst of neuroplasticity and
we see that you know very visibly in
young children
um around the teenage years there's some
pruning of the brain to sophisticate it
for adulthood for sexual behavior
emotional and social interaction
and that is quite an active process till
we're about 25. we used to think it
stopped when we physically stopped
stopped growing around the age of 18.
but the really interesting area
for us in manifestation and the laws of
attraction is that from 25 to 65 you can
do things that keeps your brain more
plastic or flexible
and you can change the ways that you
think feel and act
so to me neuroplasticity underlies
manifestation and it's a four-step
process it starts with raised awareness
so you need to know what you want to
bring into your life or how you want
your life to look
or feel
um then it's focused attention which is
noticing
maybe you know negative thinking or
certain behaviors or relationship
patterns that are holding you back from
getting what you want
and also noticing
opportunities to get the things that you
want but really just building up your
database of okay that doesn't work for
me when I do this and you know good
things come into my life
the third part is deliberate practice so
that is
going out there and doing the things
that you need to to manifest the things
that you want into your life gotta do
the work got to do the work totally
um and the fourth part isn't really like
a step in the process but it's
accountability because it's very easy to
start particularly a new year and say
okay these are all my resolutions and
new things that I'm going to do and then
for most of us that motivation doesn't
you know remain
partly from the Neuroscience that's
because we tend to pick goals that are
too big and it's better to break them
down into bite-sized chunks and that's
the same for manifestation take small
steps towards the things that you want
so if there are some things that are
more in your control like getting fit
and healthy then start doing that and
then if there's something that's less in
your control like getting married or
having a baby then
give that a bit longer but know that you
are changing your brain by changing your
behaviors and you know you have some
form of accountability whether it's a
vision board whether it's your partner
whether it's a therapist rule number
five is reprogram your mind with Bruce
Lipton your life 95 is coming from the
program
your life is a printout of your programs
you just look at your life and recognize
simple fact the things that you like
that come into your life they come in
because you have a program to
acknowledge those things but
the things you wish desire want in your
life and you work hard to make them
happen you struggle you sweat over it
I'm putting a lot of effort in I'm gonna
make this happen why are you working so
hard and the answer is whatever that
destination is your program doesn't
support it and you're trying to use your
conscious creative mind to override the
program I say Yeah by conscious mind is
five percent programs 95 percent I go
it's not going to work very well at all
so that's why poor people stay poor and
rich people stay Rich yep that's why the
book Rich Dad Poor Dad that was exactly
what the whole point was if you grew up
with a programming of a rich family you
don't have to think programming is
subconscious your thinking might be
quite stupid I mean a former president
of ours was a relatively rich person but
not very smart in his conscious mind but
his program was how do I got how I got
rich by what he downloaded that from his
family okay and if you're in a poor
family what did you download oh Life's a
struggle it's like I can't get there as
you know you can change it I say yeah
how can you change this remember I said
well there are two minds conscious is
creative wishes and desires subconscious
hard drive with a program I say the
conscious mind being creative can learn
from anything read a self-help book oh
yeah I know how to do that I said you
read the book I give you a quiz you get
a hundred and it says yeah you know this
stuff and then I say well now that you
know the stuff that your life changed
and the answer is no
I go why the conscious mind learned from
reading a book that's not how the
subconscious mind learns so our smarts
stay up here I read the book I knew the
information I understood how it worked
blah blah blah blah blah I go yeah
that's the thinking mind that knows but
I go does that translate into
subconscious it's like oh no it doesn't
because that's not how the subconscious
mind learns you want to change the
subconscious then you have to put in the
data the way the subconscious mind
learns conscious mind creative can learn
from anything you can just go aha I just
changed my mind I can do that okay
subconscious mind habit point of habit
it resists change if a habit changes and
by definition it's not a habit anymore
so habits resist change and yet we have
these habits and we want to change them
I said how can do and I say the only way
you can change the habits is the way
that the habits were learned in the
first place I go what was that I said
first seven years your brain was at a
lower vibration than Consciousness it
was called Theta Theta is hypnosis and I
go oh so what do I do I say well you you
can't just say Okay I want to go in this
hypnosis hypnosis is part of a scale of
low vibration going high during the day
and then when you come home from work
the high vibration slows down and goes
to sleep at the lowest vibration so you
go through a range of different
vibrations as you're sleeping Awakening
calm conscious focused conscious you're
at work focused conscious and I go then
what you come home you calm down now
it's calm conscious and then I say what
then you fall asleep
I said the instant you fall asleep the
next vibration down is Theta I go that's
hypnosis I go yeah so I say then every
night
the moment you fall asleep the brain for
a short period of time is in hypnosis
Theta so I say so what well you put on
earphones or ear plugs and you go to bed
playing a program that you want to be
true in your life I say so what I say
you put it on just before you fall
asleep
and while you're still awake you
probably hear some of the program okay
but the moment you fall asleep conscious
Minds disconnect it doesn't hear
anything coming off of the program
anymore I say but what does I say ah
the subconscious mind is in Theta record
so whatever's coming through the
earphones is not going into conscious
mind but it's now being directly
downloaded into the subconscious so this
is called self-hypnosis you have to
repeat this process because the amount
of time in Theta is relatively short
before before you hit the lowest
vibration Delta which is sleep outright
okay so every night when you go to bed
just after your Consciousness falls
asleep there's a period of record
opportunity and then we put the
earphones on play the program is called
self-hypnosis that's hypnosis you're
doing it yourself okay number two you
still learn programs after age seven you
learn how to drive a car you learn how
to play an instrument I go well how'd
you do it that way I go repetition
habituation is practicing something and
repeating it and repeating it so many
times that the subconscious finally says
okay I got a pattern I got the pattern
and that pattern then becomes the Habit
well number six is get creative with
Gabby Bernstein for our audience can you
define what exactly is manifesting
manifesting is acquiring the experience
of what
of feel and being and living and
believing in that experience and then
allowing that experience to come into
form manifesting is very creative it is
the process of using your power energy
and being in that presence of your
high-powered energy and allowing that
energy to co-create with the energy
that's around you so you're vibrating at
a high frequency I'm vibrating at a high
frequency we've done a lot of work we've
cleaned up a lot of our own crap we
believe in ourselves today yeah and that
that energy of believing in ourselves
has attracted us together today and
brought us into the space where we
together are co-creating and teaching if
I hadn't cleaned up my side of the
street and if I didn't believe in myself
the way I do I would never have
manifested being on marietv there's a
really nice line from A Course in
Miracles which is the metaphysical text
I teach and it is Miracles occur
naturally and when they're not occurring
something has gone wrong
that's interesting it's a good one right
so what happens is that that
synchronicity that flow that effortless
action that just sort of allowing oh I
was thinking about that and it just
showed up that's how life is supposed to
be we get in the way our negative belief
systems our fears our anxiety our our
anger towards the past that future
tripping and projecting all of that
energy gets in the way of allowing all
of the Miracles to occur naturally and
rule number seven the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is
visualize your goals with Dean graziosi
when you think of your goals that is the
number one thing everybody talks about
instead of setting a goal looking
forward
right let's pretend it is one year from
today and we're back here celebrating
and it was the best year of your life
that's the framework in which I would
love for you guys to look through
setting your goals instead of looking
forward through a busy life Look
Backwards at the best year of your life
and what had to happen when I say Look
Backwards and pretend it's the best year
of your life well your brain will
automatically go is oh yeah I want to be
making more money I want some more
freedom oh I want to lose that 10 pounds
oh I want to get the intimacy back in my
relationship that still I want to be
really I know it sounds like I'm
splitting hairs
you're still looking forward of what you
wish could happen
trained my brain over the last two
decades that when I do this exercise and
we have to do it right here when you do
this exercise it's not about looking
what you hope to happen
it's about saying it already happened
and how do you feel looking backwards
meaning put yourself in that spot and if
it's visualization if it's a little
quiet time if it's reflecting if it's
why you take a walk if it's in your
shower when you're meditating whatever
it is picture it like I literally I
literally can spend time thinking about
where I'm going to be in a year from now
and I can literally get goosebumps and I
can feel it as if it exists right now
you know people talk about manifesting
and all it is manifesting you got to do
the work it's not about just dreaming
and hope it happens I'm not a believer
in that a lot of people say you set the
intention the universe will deliver
you have to set it up and you
actually have to do the work you can't
just say ah I'd like to have a million
dollars in my bank account let me go
back to my old habits of surfing on the
internet and watching Netflix and hope
that million dollars shows up no we
gotta we gotta do the work so we'll get
a little deeper but the first thing is
is we must have that compelling future
of our own design and for me I literally
can put myself in this place
and I remember writing down okay this is
what Mastermind has to look like and I
remember writing down 100 miles and oh
we're going to do a big launch and we're
going to call it the knowledge business
blueprint and I remember writing it down
and I was writing down as if it already
happened I literally if you could see
the hair on my arms it's standing up
right here because I can visualize
because I've been practicing this for so
long that I visualize it and I see it
that is a great practice then once we
see it then the part that I think has to
happen as soon as I was done visualizing
I didn't go done I dreamed it up no then
I got my ass to work like who do I need
to learn from to do this who do I have
to model what patterns of successful
people who've already done this that I
could model and do in teaching this and
then I started making the list of what I
had to get done so that fantasy could
become a reality this might sound like
this is what everybody does but do we we
all agreed if we eat better and work out
more we'd be in better shape but most of
us want to be in better shape but we
don't eat better and we don't work out
more so a lot of us want to be next
level successful and we're looking for
something else magically to come along
and it's not gonna we have to visualize
what it is we want to be and if it was
the best year of Our Lives we have to
get as detailed as possible remember
fuzzy targets don't get hit
don't just say I want to be a coach
making a million dollars a year
what does that mean what kind of Coach
how many coaching sessions how many
clients do you need listen if you said I
want to be a coach and I want to make a
million dollars a year and you're
sitting with me
and I was Consulting for you I'd reverse
engineer it how many people how much do
you make per person right if you say I
can make you know it's ten thousand
dollars a year per person okay so that
means you need 100 clients okay you need
100 clients over 12 months it's going to
take you first month you might only get
five so if you get five the first month
and then the second month is seven then
the third month is is 20. how many do
you need to get I would lay out all
right first month five second month 12
third month I need 22 and I'd have a
freaking goal every month on how I could
get there and nothing would stop me I
would go back to what I teach you guys
I'd know my why I'd have my compelling
future I already visualized it I knew
how I feel once I made a million dollars
being a coach I know how I would
visualize how the people I'm coaching's
lives would change I would think about
if I'm saving marriages or helping
people eat better or learn how to sell
or learn how to go vegan or or a million
other things I would think about the
lives I'm changing and I would literally
craft the plan saying okay a million
dollars
as a coach okay I need a hundred clients
that's an average of 10-ish eightish a
month right whatever that is
I might not get as many the first ones
so I got to stack up the other months
and then I'd say okay what is my plan to
get the first five in January and I
would craft the plan to get my five ten
thousand dollar coaching sessions in
January and that would be my whole
Obsession and if I got four well I got
to get an extra one in February if I got
six I'm like I'm ahead of the game Let's
bust it in February and let's keep this
little cushion that I have
don't identify
with all of those thoughts that are
jumping around everywhere and this takes
a little bit of practice right because
what might happen is
um let's think of some situation you're
at work and your boss kind of gets into
you about something and that's usually
when the monkey mind appears right when
you're upset and then it's just like
great got all this energy I'm gonna go
crazy boss always picks on me bus does
this what's this that and so when you
have a situation like that where the
mind is doing that just notice the mind
just notice it the minute that you
notice it you are no longer believing it
and your mind is going into the
background if you would just notice
those thoughts instead of believing
those thoughts so if your boss space you
out and then you and then you start to
have all of those thoughts and you know
what you might be two hours later you
might be the next morning and you've
still got all the thoughts coming and
then you suddenly remember notice the
thoughts
that is fantastic that you've remembered
because that noticing disempowers the
mind the more that you can notice and
not identify with those thoughts that
you don't want the weaker and weaker the
mind will get the negativity in the mind
and soon it's just going to be like a
little lamb that you can use for
whatever you want because that's all
that's the only reason why we created
the mind we created the mind for my this
is what my teacher told me this and I
love it we created the mind for one
reason to to manifest what we want on
Earth that's why we've got it it's not
our psychologist it doesn't know
anything about psychology it's not our
psychiatrist it doesn't know anything it
doesn't know anything about your mum it
doesn't know anything about your best
friend or your boss so just keep it in
its right category and
um and then
you will start to lessen the impact of
your mind and that Mikey mine will start
to get quieter and quieter the beautiful
thing about monk life is half the day is
self and half the day is service that's
how you're taught to live okay so the
morning hours are for you to fill
yourself it's almost like putting on
mental emotional and physical armor like
that's what a morning routine is odd
days are tiring our days are busy our
days are draining well guess what if you
didn't put your armor on in the morning
and you're going out to battle
how many knives are going to cut you how
many swords are going to pierce you how
many wounds are you going to come home
with how many of you come back home
feeling wounded
I come back home feeling wounded
sometimes but guess what if you put your
armor on in the morning a warrior would
never go out onto a Battlefield
and life can be a battlefield work can
be full of conflict sometimes your
relationships can be damaging sometimes
your friendships can be toxic sometimes
so we are warriors in one sense and so
without wearing that so for me a morning
routine is putting on emotional armor
which is meant to protect you for the
rest of the day and that way even if you
do get pierced or you do get popped or
you do get cut you're protected and I
know that when I my morning routine is
at its best I feel protected exactly
whereas when my morning routine is
weakened I feel weak and so for me the
morning routine as I get strategic about
it there's two principles you have to
know
location has energy and time has memory
if you do something in the same place
every day that place now holds that
energy
and this is huge like it's it's just so
big and I'm grateful for that reaction
because people don't realize how how
powerful this is like when I meditated
in temples that were 5 000 years old in
South India it was easier to meditate
because people have been meditating
there for thousands of years and so when
you find a space in your home and even
if you've got like I lived in a 500
square foot apartment in New York four
years ago and I just had a tiny Corner
which I dedicated to my sacred practices
so if you you don't have to have a big
home to do this you don't have to be
wealthy to do this you can find just a
corner in your home that you dedicate as
your meditation space or your reflection
space so first thing location has energy
second thing time has memory and this is
something that people underestimate when
you do something at the same time every
day
you remember it
and time remembers it that's why we
struggle to work out at different times
every day it's why we struggle like why
do we feel hungry at the same time every
day generally before hungry at the same
time most people if you've got regulated
diet you're full hungry you'll feel
tired at the same time every day you
will look towards that coke can or that
sugar or that chocolate bar at the same
time every day
and so when you're meditating at the
same time if you're exercising at the
same time so what I recommend to people
wow is your morning routine needs four
aspects and it's simple and I call it
time it's about making time in the day
okay so time stands for t-i-m-e T stands
for thankfulness there needs to be even
if it's five minutes five minutes of
thankfulness of gratitude every single
morning and that has to be gratitude
that's specific it can't be gratitude
that's generic so generic gratitude is
something that anyone could be grateful
for oh I'm grateful for the sky I'm
grateful for air I'm grateful for water
that's cool but it's generic gratitude
specific gratitude is I'm grateful for
the fact that I have someone calling me
this morning I'm grateful for the fact
that I can still call my parents I'm
grateful for the fact that I have this
person in my business who is having such
an impact I'm grateful you know it's
specificity yeah so thankfulness second
one is Insight I think this is one thing
that a lot of people are missing which I
recommend people listening to you it's
like podcast books and and make it
easier for yourself if you get this book
leave it open on your bedside table
leave it open on your kitchen table
leave it open on your dining table I
guarantee you you will read more and
what you read will speak to you and I
think people underestimate that that
literally like when you have it open and
you'll just flick to a chapter randomly
and you'll pick up one line it will
impact you and it'll speak to you so
Insight you need Insight every day m is
meditation and I believe meditation is
different for different people as monks
we did walking meditations we did Beach
meditations we did visualizations we did
breath work find your meditation
practice I give a ton in the book and
fourth obviously exercise which you can
speak to even more than I can I exercise
to keep fit you look amazing too though
but it's an exercise everyone needs to
find five minutes a day 15 minutes a day
of exercise just give yourself
permission
to want the things that you want and
unless you believe that you're worthy
unless that you practice love you're
never going to think that you deserve
the things that you want right so tell
the story
okay so I'm probably gonna I mean
I'll shorten it so the bottom line is
that so in
1990 I was a senior in college at
Dartmouth and my parents came to visit
from Western Michigan and we went to
this place called Simon Pierce which is
a famous glass blowing Mill
and as we walked into the restaurant I
had an experience
that you may be able to relate to and
that is I walked in and I immediately
saw this painting hanging on the wall
and it was about the size of a door only
horizontal and it was a Vermont
landscape and I was drawn into it
immediately like I was no longer in that
restaurant I was standing in that field
I could feel that breeze I'd never ever
had an experience like that with a
painting if you ever had an experience
like that with art no I mean not like
that not like that I mean my yeah my
sense was that this is very atypical for
you very so I
kind of lost it the the the the
restaurant was quiet and then
I leaned back and suddenly kind of back
in the moment I'm like I'm gonna own
this painting someday it just that was
what was right there and I looked at the
price and said like three thousand
dollars I'm like not today and I went
back and I sat down and that was it but
the painting never left my mind you see
there's something called The zeigon Arc
effect I always say it wrong but it's
like there's a checklist in your brain
that when you have a moment where you're
like this is important your brain puts
it on a checklist yeah it's like a notch
yes a notch happens and now your brain
as part of the filter in the brain is
always going to be kind of scanning the
subconscious to let anything into your
mind related to that incident it can be
positive by the way like with the
painting or this is how trauma happens
too like you have this high intensity
emotional experience that notches
something in your brain and now your
brain kicks in to remember
so uh bottom line is uh I always thought
about that painting
years go by
whenever somebody would say Vermont I'd
think of the painting
I don't know why I can't explain it
never wanted a painting before was not
an art student it's going to Lost like
you're not collecting Arts no no no and
so I you know fast forward the story 10
years and my uh Chris and I are engaged
and we're going to go up to Vermont to
see the leaves and immediately I'm like
we got to go to Simon Pierce I got to
show you the painting so we pull up to
the mill and we walk in and right in
front there is Boom a painting by the
same artist Gail Shepard and I'm like oh
my God it's here and we race all around
the place
and it's gone
and the funny thing was and this is the
way your brain works Chris was more
disappointed than I was
I literally turned to him and said it's
okay dude like it'd be weird if we're
still here after 10 years I'm gonna
track this thing down I actually said to
him you know what's gonna happen Chris
I'm gonna be able to buy this like 40
years from now it's going to be hanging
in the corporate Lobby of some building
and I'm gonna have to track down the
owner and pay like quadruple the money
they pay but I'm gonna own this thing
I'm Mission yes so a couple years pass
and
um it's my birthday I think I was
turning 30 and Chris says uh Chris gets
a couple people too
give money and he said I could buy
anything I wanted with it so I had what
500 bucks now I'm pregnant at the time
with our first kid
I should have bought a crib or stools
but for whatever reason the zeigon arc
effect takes over I'm like the painting
so I call the mill and I get this guy on
the phone I'm like uh you know I want to
buy a kale Shepherd piece and I said
could you send me Polaroids and he's
like sure and I tell him the budget and
he goes I'll send you Polaroids of some
of her smaller things
and she's like blowing up in the
meantime right yeah she's a very very
successful Vermont landscape artist and
so I
I I say to him you know by the way
there's this one painting
and I describe the painting I'd seen
over 10 years ago and he said well that
was way before my time but I bet Gail
will know
and I'm like Gail you know Gail he's
like of course I know Gail she like
lives in in down the road
here's her number
so for two days I paced around the
apartment with 500 bucks in my pocket
driving Chris crazy because I felt like
what am I going to say to her and I must
be a weirdo I've been stalking this lady
I've been thinking about her for 10
years I can't afford a painting you know
what who am I to buy a painting like
what the hell
so finally Chris is like would you call
her I'm gonna call her you're driving me
crazy so I call her and I start talking
a mile a minute and she was amazing
and then
um I said by the way there was this one
painting and I go and I explain this
painting there's a stand of poplar trees
down the center and a big mountainscape
behind it and this beautiful blue
Vermont sky and geese flying information
overhead and
I could hear her thinking on the other
end of the line
and she said you know Mel I've done so
many large-scale
uh paintings over the years I'd hate to
mistake the one you're talking about but
I'll tell you what
what if my husband and I meet you and
Chris at the Mill at Simon Pierce and
we'll walk all around and have lunch and
I'll tell you the stories behind every
painting and if you don't see what you
like there I'll take you back to my
studio which is a couple miles down the
river and you can look at everything I'm
working on and if you don't see anything
you like there then you can go through
all my slides and see if you can find
that painting that you saw 10 years ago
and I said deal
so a month passes we go up to the mill I
walk in we meet each other she's amazing
she's like twice our age just incredibly
cool lady she's walking around as we're
walking around looking at these
paintings Rich I've got I'm like eight
months pregnant I'm realizing
these are 10 times the amount of money
that I have
I can't afford this
like I don't I don't have this kind of
money
and I'm getting like more and more into
that imposter syndrome what am I doing
mode oh my God I'm so embarrassed I'm
meeting somebody I idolize I don't
deserve to be here right wasting her
time because she thinks she's going to
get a Payday out of this correct we sit
down
and she goes now that you're sitting
down I have something to tell you
um
she said there's only been two times in
my career as an artist
that I've done two studies of the same
peace
and your painting is one of them
it's one of a pair
she knew all along she knew all along
she was playing games with you about not
knowing which painting yeah and she said
the sister piece to the one that you saw
all those years ago is sitting in my
studio right now where it's been for the
past 11 years
I start sobbing everybody's like totally
emotional her husband's like you should
have seen her when you when she was on
the phone with you it was like she saw a
ghost so we get in the car
and we drive to the mill
and when we walk in they're in the
center of this massive kind of Barn
Studio space is an easel with a painting
taped up with painters tape on it and it
was
the sister to my painting there were
slight differences not as much movement
in the grass but it was
one of the most extraordinary
experiences of my life it was as if time
suspended and I was
standing before that painting in 1990
saying it would be mine
and there I was 11 years later
standing in front of it
and then I realized oh my God I can't
afford this
and Chris walks over and he's like
what's wrong and I'm like just promise
me someday like promise me that I don't
need a jewelry I don't need a car like
just promise me you will buy me this
thing and he kind of leans over and goes
hey Gail how much for the big one and
she said um
Mel can have it for 500 bucks because
clearly when I was making it 11 years
ago I was making it for her
and so it hangs in my kitchen
it's on the back of the book
um this is the galley though right so
wait is it in the is it I think so yeah
yeah and
um it's a reminder every day that your
mind is designed to help you get what
you want
I never stop believing
that I could make it happen
and when you tell your mind what's
important to you
there is extraordinary science
that proves that your mind has a live
and ever-changing filter a live Network
that changes how it views the world What
it lets in what it blocks out and if you
program your mind correctly
and if you're clear about what you want
to create your mind will help you get
what you want when you have a goal in
your head it's not even a goal it's a
fantasy it's a dream when you have a
book like this you can call it your goal
book and you write out your goals and
you go through I'm just about to take
you through bit by bit stage by stage
you go back to that but you can look at
it you can touch it you can just make it
real so remember if you do not write out
your goals as a plan and write out how
to accomplish them you don't have a goal
you have a wish you have a dream you
have a Daydream if you want to go get a
pen get a nice little book like this you
can do on your phone too you can make a
document in your computer
and be prepared to make your goals real
so let's start now get your book pause
this if you need to go and find one
create one and I want you to pick a goal
and do not even start with I want to
lose five pounds I want more money these
are what I call wishy washy girls no
if you can make your goals real you
might as well make them huge big
enormous phenomenal so if you say well I
want more money that's why I could go
hang on a minute hey I got ten dollars
here there you go you go well that's not
my goal but you said I want more money
and I learned this when I used to work
with women who were infertile that come
and go you know I just want to be
pregnant I want to be pregnant so bad if
I was just praying I go well as I look
at your notes you've been pregnant six
times I know I keep miscarrying
so being pregnant is not your goal is it
what
isn't your goal to carry to full term a
healthy robust bouncing baby to deliver
a perfect baby to be a great man yeah
that's my goal why don't you say that
because you can be pregnant lots of
times and never have a baby or you can
say my goal is to have a perfect baby
how about this my goal is to get lots of
attention for what a nervous twitch
explosive gas that will give you
attention but that's not what you want
is it nobody wants exclusive gas
so let's start with a big goal pause if
you need to
take some time open your book
and write out a big goal now you can
have a career goal and whatever I'm
going to have my own company create my
own business invent something you can
have a relationship goal my relationship
is wonderful we grow in loving and
respecting each other and you can have a
health goal
but I want you to pick one only one not
three not five not ten one goal it can
be career it can be health
can be love pick one goal
and then I want you to decide why you
want that goal so much so the first
thing is I have a goal I want to have my
own business that's my goal and now
you're going to go to a next page and
write out why do you want to have your
own business so much and the more
reasoned you can write out why the more
likely
you will make that goal real so write
down why write down as many why's as you
can remember
you can come back any time to this and
think Oh I thought of another why and
another why to leave plenty of space
take your time and when you've done your
whys go to another page and write out
who will benefit from you achieving that
goal of course you will but who who will
benefit for instance if you have your
own business
you will employ people who will benefit
maybe your kids will go to private
school maybe your business will allow
you to help your partner have their
business
the more people who will benefit from
you achieving your goal the more reasons
you have
to achieve that goal so write out who
will benefit from you achieving a Who
how and why will they benefit you're
going to buy your mama house put your
niece and nephew through private school
did you think of your mind as like the
genie in a bottle that says your wish is
my command
I want you to understand that every
thought you think and every word you say
is a blueprint that your mind body and
psyche must make real so when you write
out your goals don't say I wish I could
be rich
I long to be in a loving relationship
write it as if it's already happening I
am a millionaire I am in a loving
relationship Michael that doesn't make
sense it does make sense because your
mind only works in the present tense
when you say next year I'll have a
bikini body it doesn't know what next
year is
and so you must write your both in the
present tense I am I always I have I do
this new page is about your discipline
how many hours a day are you going to
spend working on your goal
how often are you going to come back to
this book and look at it I want you to
write out I am
I always I have I do and I want you to
fill that in
you see the best goal in the world will
not work if you don't work and many
people fail at this point they write out
a goal
my goal is to be a millionaire my goal
is to be famous my goal is to be wildly
in love and I think that's it
it's not it if you want to be madly in
love right are all the reasons why but
then you have got to put yourself in
front of the kind of person you want to
share your life with
if you want to start your own business
and you have a reason why you also need
to have the discipline to meet people
who will fund you sponsor you joint
venture with you so I want you to really
understand that the best goal will not
work if you don't work you can have the
start point
but you have to keep going many of the
most successful people ever say well you
know I had a goal Luther Vandross had a
goal to be a rock star
and people said well you're an overnight
success you went I don't think so you
know I sang Jingles for KFC for 12 years
that's a long night 12 years and Bill
said but Luther you're singing on
television that's cool you get paid a
lot of money for KFC I said yeah but
it's not my goal and he stuck it out and
many people have got so close to success
and had to keep going and you have to
keep going so
look at your Diesel and decide you will
give more to your girl give even more
work on it look at it write it out think
about it talk about it you must be
prepared to give so much to your goal in
fact you must be prepared to be
unstoppable in the pursuit of your goal
have you ever spent any time wondering
how does everything happen how does
everything happen why does the night
follow the day
mine isn't the day follow the day
back in some places it does
but
I spend a lot of time thinking about
this
at the times it almost drives me crazy
but like right outside of my studio here
is a Japanese maple tree
and
there's times of the year it's
absolutely beautiful
in the spring of the year it has buds on
and then the buds cologne and leaves pop
out and the leaves generally in the
spring are a very deep greeny Brown
they're not a pretty looking leaf
but then they start to change and over
time you don't notice it happening just
one day you look and it's a different
color
and by fall
the leaves are crimson red they're the
most beautiful it is the most beautiful
tree and it's right outside in my studio
I'm sitting here in my desk and
cameras around me but oh there is that
tree
and you know every fall the leaves turn
red
Every Spring there are greeny brown
they're not greeny brown in the fall and
red in the spring they're always red in
the faux and greeny brown in the spring
think about it
did you ever wonder why the tide goes
way out the tide comes way back in
I spent some time in the Navy in Canada
I was down on the East Coast for a while
and I was near the Bay of Fundy do you
know the Bay of Fundy has one of the
highest and lowest tides in the world
it's absolutely amazing it goes way out
and then comes way back in
same up around Prince George on the West
Coast
you go onto a ship and you might be
walking up a plank just right straight
up and you go off the ship sometimes
you're going right down that ship goes
way up in here and it comes way down
very high very low tide now some place
the Tide's not very big they do have a
tide but not too high not too low
why is it so different one place than
another
you know why does the leaves change
color
why do they change color
you know why does the grass keep growing
wouldn't it be so much nicer it's a
grass just you know just stayed at a
certain length you wouldn't have to cut
it but it would always look pretty
you know do you ever think about this do
you know that everything in this
universe happens in an exact way
and exactly not by chance but in an
exact way
when John Kennedy the president of the
United States actors asked Dr Warner Von
Braun who was the master mind behind the
space program we asked him what would it
take to build a rocket that would carry
a person to the moon and bring him back
safely to Earth Von Braun answered him
in five words the will to do it that's
it the will to do it
he knew he didn't have to know how to do
it he knew he had to learn how to do it
but he didn't have to know to make up
your mind you were going to do it now
why did he say that because he
understands the laws
Vine Brown runtime said after years of
studying the spectacular Mysteries of
the cosmos he was led into a firm belief
in the existence of God and he said the
natural laws of this universe are so
precise that we don't even have any
difficulty building spaceship we send
people to the moon and we can climb the
landing with the Precision of a fraction
of a second
[Music]
now he said these laws must have been
set by someone I see the laws as God's
modus operandi but I'm going to tell you
something everything happens by law when
you and I get in harmony with the law I
never do that odds are pretty good we
should understand them but when we get
in harmony with the law then I'm going
to tell you it's just smooth sailing
success
happens
probably be a good understanding good
idea to understand the laws wouldn't it
think about it
your life is governed by laws that are
not man-made so they're not going to be
man changed and if you study them and
work in harmony with them I'm going to
go shock yourself with the good you can
do now I've been doing that for the last
58 years I'm starting to get a really a
reasonable grip on them but I don't
understand them as well as I want to or
would like to
but I'm going to study a little more
today you know I get my trusty book out
here I'll have to talk to you about this
book that'll be another talk
study the laws find out what they write
what they're like
what are the laws and then study them
you'll win consistent action is the
cure-all whatever problem you have
whatever issue you're facing whatever
big life you want to create for yourself
the way to get there is not some giant
short burst of effort it's the daily
consistent grinding action that will
help you accomplish your goals people
look at my channel and
a lot of new people have joined over the
past number of years hey welcome board
great to have you welcome to believe
Nation it's a positive happy place it's
great to have you here it's an honor to
be a part of your daily routine
if you go and look at my my channel my
main channel in the history it took so
many years guys so many years of just
making content and not seeing any
results
I took I forget what the number is it
took five years to get to 9 000
something subscribers and another five
years to get almost two million
subscribers now we're sitting over three
million subscribers Etc
I haven't missed
an upload every single day
for I don't know
eight years
something crazy like that
every day
I've made videos through
travel I've made videos through elect
electricity electricity outages I made
videos through breaking my neck I made
videos through my tour I made videos
through vacation I made videos I made
videos I made videos I made videos I
made videos I made videos and you can
plan you can prepare you can get ahead
you can you can batch them
but I don't think your goals count until
they're hard
it's when it gets hard when when you get
tested that's when you have to show
yourself What You're Made Of
even little things like
I remember filming at my dance studio in
Toronto
and I have my camera guy and my
assistant and we're filming and the
electricity goes out
and then there's a fire alarm
they go I guess we can't film like the
first thing that that my camera guy says
is okay well I guess we can't film I
can't film but it's like electricity
outage and then fire alarm
you can't film with that it's like I'm
I'm filming today
so I took my phone it was freezing
outside I took my phone went outside and
just started filming
because videos have to go up
they have to go up
I've I've made videos with my broken
neck
I broke my neck in two spots had a
concussion
and I
next week I'm making videos
they weren't as long they weren't as
good
I'm wearing a neck brace if you look at
the old videos I'm wearing this giant
neck brace I got this giant scab here on
my forehead because I smashed my head
against the wall
when I fainted and that's how it led to
the concussion broken neck I'm still
making videos
not making videos is not an option
and so if you look at someone like me
who
is introverted is shy who doesn't like
the camera who always thought that
people who are famous had a big ego who
I still don't like being on stage I
still get nervous every single time
but I still have a message
and I still want to serve how does
somebody like that
have this kind of Channel well because
of every single day making videos you've
done over 10 000 videos I've done over
10 000 videos that's crazy
not all of them are public
but even just on the main Channel let
alone this channel on the top 10 channel
the other channel 10 000 Plus videos
over 12 years
why
how
it's just a consistent action
I think most people lose because
we overestimate what we can do
in a really
short period of time and underestimate
what we can do in a long period of time
you think by putting in three weeks of
hard work you're gonna crush it
but really if you just stayed on it like
guys you've had ideas you have enough
you have had an idea
that you'd love that you gave up on too
soon that if you just kept doing it this
is an idea that you had maybe three
years ago that if you just found the way
to keep doing it even part-time even on
the side even on the weekends if you
just kept at it you'd be in a different
place right now
something would have happened something
would have paid off
but we're too frustrated to get
something to happen right now and I get
it I'm there too I'm I'm impatient I
want immediate results I want things to
happen I'm putting my best I want this
video right now to be the best one I've
ever done and I put my effort to try to
make that happen and I fully recognize
at the same time that
it's a long game
that you have to keep going
and that if it's your purpose you can't
give up on it
most people just quit too soon
you just quit too soon
and that's you quitting on your dream
and if it's your dream and you want it
to happen it's a daily consistent
action to make it happen
so how do you do it let me give you some
tactics so that you can not just get
motivated from a message but actually
apply it to your life number one you
have to create a calendar
these videos happen because you're in my
calendar
I'm filming this on a Tuesday Tuesday is
my YouTube day I always film on Tuesday
I block it off in my calendar
I just came back from vacation and on
the Tuesday of my week I was still
making videos people say well still work
on vacation first off it's not work like
I like this this is fun for me this
isn't this isn't oh I have to go make
videos if that was my mindset I would
I'd be out I wouldn't do it anymore
but also if you're on vacation you're
making videos or you're doing a little
bit of work
spend three hours
of a 24-hour day
doing something
is totally achievable somebody uh one of
the people that I invested into
yesterday's like how do I take a
vacation on my business
like how do I my wife wants to know how
do I go on vacation and run this
business like you can still you can
either plan ahead and get ahead with all
your clients or you can still do some
work
do you not have personal time are you
going to be around your wife 24 hours a
day does your wife not want to go to the
spa or spend some time on the beach it's
not about the three hours that you spend
working it's about
the other hours at 21 hours you get to
sleep but whatever all the other hours
that you have the day it's about
intentional time most of most people's
life is not intentional most of your
vacation time is not intentional either
if you were to spend 21 hours a day with
your wife
intentionally creating an amazing
relationship
then the three hours a day you're going
to spend working
as easy as nothing
of course you could take time off
but you have to put in your calendar
you have to create a calendar that makes
sense for you schedule in when you're
actually going to make your dreams
happen because otherwise it's a dream I
could say I want to make YouTube videos
but if it was never my calendar guess
what it would never happen and this
applies for life too every uh every
afternoon
at 2 30 I spend time with Nina with my
wife
we spend time in the morning I take an
intentional break at 2 30 we go to the
park we take we take the dogs with us
we we stay inside and just be together
if it's raining like we'll spend time
every day every weekday at 2 30 because
I want I wanted to spend more time with
Nina during the week weekends we're
basically all in on on the relationship
but the weekdays can be crazy you know
so we spend time in the morning we spend
time in the evening and I wanted to
spend 2 30. it's 25 minutes together but
intentional 25 minutes that intentional
25 minutes is worth more than three
hours of just sit in front of a TV
that's not time together
you have a lot more time than you think
you're just not being intentional that's
the problem if you feel like you got to
the end of the week and you were so busy
but you got nothing done
and everything's falling apart you're
just not intentional with your time
so you schedule it in whatever you
wanted a life whatever your dream life
looks like whatever your goals Ambitions
motivations are put in your calendar
two
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
stop letting yourself off the hook
for not following through on your
calendar
I'm a little tired today because we just
came back from our trip I'm a little jet
lagged from coming out from the West
I'm still making videos I'm still videos
have to be made they're going up like
when do you let yourself break
if it's in the calendar it has to happen
videos have to happen today I don't care
if I'm lying in bed I don't care I don't
care if I'm in the hospital I've made
videos from the hospital I don't care
where videos have to come up I don't
care if they're the best videos they're
the best
with what I can make right now
if I'm tired they might be lower than my
standard
but it's the best of what I can make
right now if I'm in the hospital it's
definitely lower than what I can make
out of the hospital but it's gonna make
the best of what I can make right now
be the person who follows through on the
things that you say you're gonna do
because the next time you put something
in your calendar the next time we see
you're gonna get that goal or
do this project you're going to the next
day wake up I'm not I can't do that I'm
not doing that
you're starting to build the identity
either way of the person who follows
through or the person who doesn't follow
through
and every time you say yes to yourself
every time you do it when it's difficult
you start to build up that identity a
little bit more I follow through I
follow through I follow through so then
the next time you put something in your
calendar the next time come up with a
goal you start to believe that it's
actually possible for you to do it
because you're building that identity of
you being the person who actually
follows through
and every time you let yourself off the
hook every time you give yourself a
break every time you say it's okay I'm
not going to do it today every time you
say that
you eat away at that other identity and
start to build a new one
the new identity of the person who
doesn't follow through
you start to believe yourself a little
bit less
the next goal you write down is a little
less credible you don't think you can do
it you're going to realize the next day
that you're not going to follow through
it's very
slippery slope to fall down
so step one is you build a calendar step
two is you become the person who sticks
to your calendar
who follows through on the things that
you say you're gonna do that's why it's
important to create a realistic calendar
don't tell me don't tell yourself you're
gonna make 100 videos a day every day
you're going to make a thousand phone
calls a day every day
you're not you're going to write 100
love letters to your wife every day
you're not you're not it's not going to
happen make it a realistic plan for
something you can actually stick to
because again if you just stick to it
guys you will hit your goals
if you stop quitting on yourself if you
stop letting yourself off the hook that
idea you had three years ago should have
already come to Creation because you
just stuck with it just stick with it
step number three so create a calendar
one stick to your calendar number two
three
the environment around you really
matters
videos like this really matters why
create the inspressor to be with you
every morning to give you the Boost to
bring you people like John Ashraf and
Oprah and Elon Musk and these people who
lift you up who inspire you hopefully
that's the intention every time
join a group like movement makers be a
part of a community be around other
entrepreneurs who are doing things we're
chasing their dreams we're trying to
make their thing happen when you're when
you create that environment and you
start to shift it
it inspires you to want to play bigger
it inspires you to want to stay
consistent when you are feeling at your
lowest low when you're about to quit on
the thing that you said that you want to
do that's in your calendar you see it
you see it today I'm supposed to do that
like I don't want to do that what brings
you out of it
it's the habits it's the environment
it's the routine
watch another video
join our group like movement makers
get a mentor coach
have an accountability buddy
you have to be around the people who
constantly fill your cup who give you
light who lift you up who make you
believe and help you feel like it's
possible when you do those three things
your life will change
create a calendar
that Maps your actions to your ambitions
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
and then be around the people videos
resources environment
that encourages you that lifts you up
and makes you feel like it's possible
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to turn your Visions into reality
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there now think about
three-dimensional reality many people
can develop the skills to become
successful they can make the right
choices they can study real hard they
can practice they can get trained but
they're going to follow certain rules of
Newtonian physics it's just going to
take time